[Music]
on this sunday night a dead heat on the
eve of election day
the liberals barnstorm across canada
sharpening attacks on conservative
opponents in a tight battle not leading
on vaccinations also means he's not
leading on the economy the conservative
leaders anti-trudeau appeal in the final
push for voters mr trudeau
put us into
a 600 million dollar election
plus the ndp on the offensive the
ridings they're trying to swing orange
in the last sprint we think that mr
o'toole and mr trudeau would be bad for
canada and a landmark flight the world's
first all-civilian orbital crew makes a
safe splashdown
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight nitu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are into the final hours of the
federal election campaign leaders of the
three main parties spent time near their
home ridings today where they'll watch
the results roll in tomorrow night after
36 days of campaigning it could be a
photo finish an ips's poll done
exclusively for global news shows the
liberals and conservatives neck and neck
the tories are on track to receive 32
percent of the decided popular vote
while the liberals would get 31 percent
the ndp is poised to receive 21 percent
of ballots cast
every vote is critical and liberal
leader justin trudeau spent his last day
on the campaign trail trying to win over
as many canadians as possible abigail
beeman is traveling with the liberal
campaign abigail
justin trudeau's final day of
campaigning is taking him across the
country and at his first stop in
montreal he made his strongest push yet
to link covet struggles in western
provinces to conservative leader aaron
o'toole we're seeing right now what the
wrong choices made in alberta and
saskatchewan have led to we do not need
a conservative government that won't be
able to show the leadership on
vaccinations and on science that we need
to end this folks in alberta have a
really important choice to make whether
they want aaron o'toole to continue
working with jason kenney on not ending
this pandemic
wrong choices a strong choice of words
considering trudeau has been careful
about criticizing provincial
conservative leaders so a pitch to
western voters who largely shut out the
liberals in 2019 and a pitch to
progressive voters which he has been
doing more consistently the last few
days trying to ward off vote flitting
for people who would consider voting ndp
or green trudeau once again called on
those voters to look at the liberal
option especially on climate change
the party choosing to spend even more
time here in southern ontario part of a
third day in a row playing both offense
and defense with seats they're trying to
win and ones they're trying to save
abigail beeman global news niagara falls
ontario
i'm mike laquiteur with the conservative
campaign in toronto where instead of
hitting the hustings early sunday aaron
o'toole went for an 11 kilometer jog
before his first mid-morning event
okay that's the warm-up john you guys
ready for the real round now there's
seemingly no sense of urgency in this
last run to the finish line as the
tories target liberal held ridings in
the vote rich toronto suburbs it's all
about ground game a part of that ground
game is to hit as many ridings as you
can in the final day of campaigning
o'toole had just four events scheduled
we need medicare for autism in markham
his message to campaign workers was
drowned out by a protester
even though he had told media he would
take questions at the event o'toole was
whisked out a side door and into a
waiting car will you scrub it all today
and there remain unanswered questions
for o'toole like the vaccination status
of all of his candidates oakville
candidate carrie colburn is fully
vaccinated and that seems to be an
important issue for her electors i do
get talked about vaccines a fair bit at
the door both people that want mandates
and people that don't so
as i said i personally believe in
vaccination but like o'toole colburn
says getting vaccinated is a personal
choice
[Applause]
[Music]
o'toole's former military brother
retired general rick hillier endorsed
him saturday night but he doesn't seem
to share the same opinion as o'toole
when it comes to disclosing candidates
vaccine status i don't know all the
candidates in the conservative party of
canada i don't know all the ones in the
liberals or the ndp or the green party
i'm not sure who's vaccinated or not i
think they all should be with just hours
to go in this race a senior conservative
source tells global news there is
concern there will be a lot of close
ridings in this election and unlike in
2019 they say there will be no moral
victory if the tories win the popular
vote but still don't form government
michael couture global news toronto
i'm robin gill with the ndp campaign in
vancouver bc is the final stop for judd
meet singh it's home to his riding and
it's the province where the party has
the most support
the odds are against judgment singh
becoming prime minister but he can play
a pivotal role in a minority government
when asked if he could support the
conservatives he didn't rule that out i
would say to someone who's worried about
what's going to happen next that let's
just look at what's happened in the past
parliament ideologically he's more
aligned with the liberals but he's taken
a lot of shots at justin trudeau in the
past six years mr trudeau was in
government and so our critique is going
to be about government decisions
naturally and mr trudeau was in power
for those six years so we want people to
know these are the decisions that he
made and this is what we think is wrong
with those decisions the ndp has spent
most of its time on the offensive in
what's known as the classic whistle stop
singh has hit eight ridings in the
vancouver area on the final day the ndp
needs to get more than the 24 seats the
party won in the last election say you
don't grow more seats or it's very
minimal do you think you will have
failed your party
no we're confident that we're going to
do well in this campaign it's the end of
a short campaign with long hours since
personal popularity has pulled high
consistently but parlaying that into
votes has been challenging in the past
still with the minority government in
the forecast he could be back on the
campaign trail very soon even judge meat
singh described it as groundhog day
nithu
robin gill reporting tonight in
vancouver thanks robin
we may not even know the true outcome of
the election by tomorrow night more than
1.2 million special ballot voting kits
were issued this campaign which include
those mail-in ballots elections canada
expects the majority will be counted by
wednesday but says the full count could
take up to four days we will have
extensive coverage on election night
monday anchored by global nationals
donna friesen right here on global
television as well as on history global
news radio and various online platforms
including globalnews.ca
the revealing of hundreds of unmarked
graves near former residential school
sites this year prompted a national
reckoning but separating indigenous kids
from their home communities and families
is not just a part of canada's painful
past there are more indigenous children
in the child welfare system today than
at the height of residential schools
within the last two decades hundreds of
those children have died heather urex
west looks at the deaths of seven
children in alberta and why advocates
hope this federal election will finally
lead to change
whitney josh and greg were aged two four
and six
camden was eight chara and skye were
teenagers and trevor just 20.
the group of seven alberta first nations
children and youth died within a
14-month period in 2018-2019
their deaths the results of an
accidental fire drug toxicity sepsis and
homicide all within two years of
receiving child intervention services
alberta's child and youth advocate
investigated their deaths in a recent
report
nine children died during that period
but the fact that seven were indigenous
doesn't take advocate cindy blackstock
by surprise
we've seen
that children when they're removed from
their families and placed in child
welfare care are at higher risk for all
kinds of harms several decades after
canada closed the last residential
schools the child welfare system appears
to have taken its place
each year thousands of first nations
children are taken into the system
changing that is the truth and
reconciliation commission's number one
call to action but progress has been
slow the good news is all of us can
pressure all candidates of all parties
to stop it because they can
a big part of the problem blackstock
says is that federally funded social
services for indigenous people receive
far less than provincially funded
services non-indigenous people in canada
receive
she's been fighting the government of
canada in court for equitable funding
for child welfare since 2016. i was born
into foster care in british columbia for
ashley bach the issue is deeply personal
the 27 year old began advocating for
other indigenous foster kids soon after
she aged out of care essentially it's
transitioning into adulthood but in many
cases
it's more like being abandoned and one
of my youngest siblings now
is in the process of aging out of care
and
as much as it hurts to say this the
system really hasn't changed much
bach says she was heartened to hear the
issue of indigenous kids in care brought
up during the english language federal
leaders debate she says she hopes more
canadians will think about these
children when they cast a ballot on
election day heather yorks west global
news calgary
more than 250 afghans arrived in canada
this weekend and will soon begin a new
life they arrived at toronto's pearson
international airport saturday afternoon
via the u.s those on board included
afghan nationals and refugees as well as
interpreters and others who previously
assisted canadian forces during the
mission in afghanistan the new arrivals
will have to stay in covet 19 quarantine
before moving on to the communities
they'll call home immigration refugees
and citizenship minister marco mendicino
says the new arrivals were relieved to
be out of danger following the taliban
seizing control of the country one month
ago
more than 2 thousand people have arrived
since that time the canadian government
has promised to resettle 20 thousand
refugees from afghanistan
in the capital kabul women rallied
outside the building that housed the
country's women's affairs ministry
before the taliban takeover the militant
islamist group has rebranded it the
ministry for preaching and guidance and
the propagation of virtue and the
prevention of vice it's one of the
latest moves raising concerns about the
future of women's and girls rights today
the taliban appointed inter mayor of
kabul told female city employees to
remain home with the exception of those
whose jobs could not be filled by men
the taliban has also imposed measures
limiting or preventing access to
education for women and girls
i'm ross lord in saint john's
newfoundland and labrador there's
widespread apprehension here as a
provincial government that's drowning in
debt considers how to fix the finances
without punishing its people that story
coming up on global national
there is fear in the province of
newfoundland and labrador about what's
coming next as we reported yesterday a
crippling financial crisis has liberal
premier andrew fury considering his
options as ross lord reports
newfoundlanders are struggling to
foresee a solution that doesn't cause
more
pain with the worst debt load and
highest unemployment in canada the
government of newfoundland and labrador
has signaled a shakeup is coming to
straighten out the province's finances
even five billion dollars in federal
funding for cost overruns at the muskrat
falls hydro project won't solve the
crisis something most newfoundlanders
seem to recognize we need to get things
back on track and kind of relying on the
federal government to bail us out is not
a reliable solution truly fixing the
finances could mean making structural
changes something premier andrew fury
has yet to do
as fury considers his options the
province is in a state of apprehension
we're all waiting on the edge seeing
things get worse
but with the potential that maybe oil
prices may get a bit better in the next
couple of years but at some point here
we need someone to stand up and say i
know this is going to hurt but we're
going to pull that tooth for now fury is
keeping people guessing through his
office he agreed to an interview with
global news then abruptly pulled out and
there was no response to our request to
reschedule
among those most nervous about what's
coming are the province's public
servants they wonder if their crowded
parking lots will soon be thinned out
their union cautions the government
against cutting services to the public
like health care that's a concern
they're trying to balance
how we deal with things not making big
mistakes
that will have a further negative
consequence here in our province a
province that's endured a series of
economic collapses including the cod
moratorium is once again on the brink of
financial disaster it's the result of a
big increase in government spending when
oil prices were high followed by the
crash in oil prices then the pandemic to
successful business owners like todd
perrin it's a shame considering his
province is a warehouse of natural
resources be it fisheries be it oil and
gas whatever you feel about how we
should be prosecuting the oil and gas
industry hydro
you know forestry mining
you know it's a it's a huge warehouse of
all of the things that the world wants
and needs he hopes the province will
realize its full potential once and for
all after it emerges from its latest
financial crisis
ross lord global news st john's
newfoundland and labrador
coming up a french slackliner wows the
crowd with epic eiffel tower
entertainment
a frightening sight on the spanish
island of la palma today a volcano is
erupting shooting huge plumes of smoke
and lava into the sky authorities
immediately evacuated more than 1 000
people but spain's civil guard now says
it may need to evacuate up to 10
thousand residents
a french daredevil is taking
entertainment to new heights in paris
the 27 year old tightrope artist
thrilled thousands of onlookers along
the banks of the sen river he walked 600
meters on a slack line more than 70
meters above the ground the tightrope
star even performed some stunts along
the way
space history has been made again the
first all-amateur crew to circle the
world without an astronaut aboard has
safely returned to earth spacex founder
elon musk picked them as his first
rocket riding tourists and as jennifer
johnson reports four more flights with
paying customers are coming soon
a dragon continuing to descend the
spacex crew dragon capsule made a
splashy entrance back to earth with four
space tourists aboard inspiration four
on behalf of spacex welcome home to
planet earth your mission has shown the
world that space is for all of us
no professional astronaut was on this
trailblazing three-day trip to space
38-year-old billionaire jared isaac man
chartered the flight paying undisclosed
millions for himself and three guests
so big part of our mission here at
inspiration four is to inspire what can
be done here in space isaac man aimed to
raise 200 million dollars for st jude
children's research hospital donating
100 million himself spacex founder elon
musk donated another 50 million
one of the tourists aboard was a saint
jude physician assistant who was a bone
cancer patient at the hospital nearly
two decades ago and did some research
while in space it's been really
interesting to see how fluid shifts with
this microgravity environment and that's
something that scientists are looking at
and so we're happy to contribute with
that arsenal's journey was an
inspiration for her young cancer
patients who did a question and answer
session with the space taurus can you
fall in space since there is no gravity
i have to say that floating is
i don't know if you saw i guys called
that peanut m m floating is so much fun
what's your favorite space food
my favorite space food is pizza which i
had yesterday looks like a smooth ride
for the crew the capsule literally ran
circles around other space tourism
competitors going 161 kilometers past
the international space station and
orbiting the earth 15 times a day
and there will be more early next year
three businessmen paying 55 million
dollars each will fly to the space
station accompanied by nasa astronauts
jennifer johnson global news washington
a boxing star from the philippines is
getting ready to throw his hat into a
different ring by running for president
of his country in 2022
we are ready to rise
to the challenge of leadership
42-year-old boxer and senator manny
pacquiao accepted the nomination of his
party saying filipinos are ready for a
change of government president rodrigo
duterte who led a brutal war against
illegal drugs is constitutionally unable
to seek a second six-year term but has
accepted a vice presidential nomination
up next the federal candidate in bc
going from paralympian to politician
there may be thousands of people across
the country running in this election
hoping to become a member of parliament
but there's no one quite like josh
vandervees this week our mike armstrong
has been looking at candidates with
interesting backstories and tonight he
introduces us to the liberal candidate
in the riding of vancouver east he's a
former paralympian a man with no arms no
legs and as you'll see no limits
yes one two three
all right he isn't one to beat around
the bush
invited to speak this week to the
vancouver east end boys club josh
vanderveese opens with a question think
to yourselves what what would it be like
if you didn't have any arms and legs now
van der vees has spent a lifetime
working on breaking the ice making that
first impression to put people he meets
at ease not a bad skill to have if
you're running for office when i was a
boy i learned how to write by
holding the pen or pencil between my arm
and cheek
and writing like this
and
it's ironic because
the teachers always said i had the best
handwriting in the
class the other skill that's translated
well is what van der vees does with
things that scare him he says he was
terrified making the jump into politics
and starting this campaign
ignoring fear is just what it's all
about growth happens outside of your
comfort zone
well vandervees has lived a life outside
what most would consider a comfort zone
and he's not really a big fan of being
told he can't do something he was born
without arms and legs and with very
supportive parents developed an aversion
to limiting himself as a boy he says he
watched jean crazier and dreamed of
going into politics excellent not for
the power but for the profile the chance
to be seen and make people think
oh can the mp in my riding can he
actually get into my store
or are there stairs or you know are we
designing vehicles that work for
someone in a wheelchair like my mp
nice sure van der vee spent a decade as
a paralympian competing in bocce he won
a bronze medal in london in 2012. after
that he went to law school and as a
lawyer works with not-for-profit groups
he's married with a daughter and a
stepson and has held on to that passion
for taking on challenges his opponent
got more than 50 percent of the vote in
the last election
it's not my first uphill battle having
the odds against him doesn't seem like
something van der vee's let's get in his
way
mike armstrong global news
what an inspiration and that is global
national for this sunday night i'm nitu
garcia tonight your canada is esther
hazy saskatchewan donna friesen will be
back at the anchor desk tomorrow and she
will host our special election coverage
throughout the evening thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]